bom eu sempre fui extremamente fascinado
e 10
a idéia é qualidade
eu acho fascinante alguma coisa na
cabeça de uma pessoa
neste momento
materializado na realidade o mundo
acontecendo em volta de um dia na cabeça
e um outro motivo
por isso entender os processos que fazem
com que isso aconteça
eu acho isso muito legal e o ponto de
querer fazer um convite vamos então já
que tem uma coisa que eu acredito que é
ter a realidade transformada ea maneira
de fazer essa transformação é seguir
nesse processo
a idéia seria uma maneira de ela se
tornar realidade
eu queria fazer um convite e quem tem
uma ideia na cabeça e precisa que ela
vire realidade eu gostei
na verdade é isso e telefone celular
essa luizinho sem problemas
vamos ver nosso ver nossa várias delas
não têm forte atrás muito legal
bom então eu tô toda a potência é o fato
é que imagine se todas as idéias que
foram levantadas hoje se tornar
realidade
assim como já aconteceu contra a ideia é
alguém mais intensa
nossa eu poderia fazer alguma coisa para
fazer não tinha comida tudo mais tempo
uma vez por ano ea noite
agora se a gente tem uma idéia o
trânsito ou se envolverem hoje poderia
ter atitudes mais éticas ou se alguém
tem uma idéia e como nós poderíamos ter
conversas melhores do que nós todos os
clubes que ascenderão virasse realidade
legal não seria necessário que essas
coisas se tornassem realidade ou seja o
tamanho da transformação da realidade do
financista que deixa extremamente
frustrado e triste é o fato de que quase
nenhuma dessas idéias se torne realidade
é esse tipo de coisa acontecer na nossa
vida é assim deve ficar para trás eo
mundo
ele é extremamente hostil à idéia de
reais feita aqui já tentou materializar
uma ideia sabe qual é a utilidade do
mundo sabe fator que a gente sente o
primeiro da sala as frustrações
todos os as barreiras que vão sendo
colocados à nossa frente porque acelera
se torne realidade
o fato é de poucas e 12º dele e essas
poucas ideias não causando uma pequena
transformação e é o que a gente vai
vendo
se eu tivesse data um convite pra vocês
hoje seria esse seja encontrar maneiras
de pelo menos salvar uma idéia do dia
dessas formas é de confiar um pouco mais
nelas acreditar um pouco mais nada eu
tive dentro da minha história tive a
oportunidade de ter uma idéia que aos
trancos e barrancos por todos os
percalços que a ideia passa se tornou
realidade
eu era funcionário de uma agência de
propaganda e pensei que legal seria se
nós montarmos um espaço no escritório
onde várias pessoas profissionais
autônomos empreendedores finlândia da
propaganda
o denunciante tentar fazer suas ideias
nem certo juntos e transformar em
realidade
este é fácil ter um blog este blog virou
uma lista de interessados nessa lista de
interessados terão uma pesquisa com
lista de espera e de repente nascer um
espaço pequeno espaço foi reformado e
hoje esse espaço o movimento uma rede
que várias pessoas formadoras e um
espaço de 600 metros quadrados onde nos
últimos cinco anos
alguns milhares desta forma por lá e eu
tive a oportunidade de ter perto eu
comecei em termos de seu ciclo de vida
acontecendo
sobreviveram outros morreram mas é parte
da realidade cruel de todas as idéias
estão vivendo no mundo e vou te faz é o
vasco me ajudar por exemplo conta dessa
idéia deu certo
é eu tive outras idéias elas
sobreviveram mais fácil por causa do
organizado e da rede construída
eu fui convidado para participar de
discussões do fórum econômico mundial
por conta disso é o filho é me ajuda
muito não vai excluir por conta disso
mas aquela minha fascinação que um dia
de spa com o resultado
acho que se um grande grande não tinha
sempre pude entender tal nesse factor
aqui nessa celebração de muitas idéias
acontecendo eu pude entender o que
diferencia as vezes o empreendedor é uma
pessoa ativa faz uma idéia dá certo
realizador legal pessoas que aparecem
com a idéia e por algum motivo ela não
vai pra frente e começar a observar
eu encontrei com os padrões e esse
padrão que você vai compartilhar com
vocês
talvez as mais fantásticas que estejam
aqui possam com mais facilidade para a
realidade e é o primeiro padrão mental
eu vejo que os empreendedores realizador
espaço
eles aparecem em uma sensação de que
nada mudou de idéia e eles aparecem como
protetores das suas ideias
então quando ele era nasce a idéia é
frágil não concorda e mostra pra alguém
melhor do que eu vivo sozinho
não sei se vai funcionar o cara fala
assim não mas vejo o lado mas veja bem e
de repente um ligo o rádio do ano a
idéia é o empreendedor chega e faz a
mesma coisa para todos os amigos
tentaram ideia mas tanto eu quanto eu
vou colocar na rua quando ele vai para a
realidade das pessoas que não são amigos
dele falou o seguinte se o não gosto
disso e ele e conclusão em lages na
prova dez anos
certo alguém extremamente ativa nos
mostra que não sabe entender que eles
têm essa habilidade muito grande de
gerar um movimento transformador do
tempo todo eles teriam conexões ideia é
um esporte de contato
a idéia é preciso apanhar por favor e
segundo ponto é exatamente isso que os
atores extremamente habilidosos aprendem
a usar o movimento
eles aprendem a identificar pontos onde
eles podem captar uma ideia quando eles
podem se capacitar mulheres podem gerar
aprendizado eles correm atrás
- eles sabem ele atirar coisas
extremamente importantes no dia deles
que às vezes não são as coisas urgentes
das coisas que estamos fazendo
eles podem com uma dessas coisas pra
fazer hoje eles estão sempre fazendo um
teste de uma maçã por dia uma coisa por
semana ou coisa assim
e se eles não são as pessoas mais
inteligentes ou não um filho de conexão
nenhuma inteligência e realização
não tenho pretensão nenhuma cobrança é
feita administração ou não a realização
mas eu vejo conexão absurda pessoas que
têm um peixe de movimento de realização
movimento resultado
o terceiro ponto é isso eles não estão
interessados em espaço existem
interessados em um ambiente de ambiente
uma outra coisa é quando vejo sim a
natureza começa a entender que eles
precisam dessa irregularidade e se face
eles começam a tentar criar um ambiente
que a gente pra isso começa a se
aproximar das pessoas certas
eles começam a se aproximar dos
conselhos certos eles começam a ajustar
o time no dia deles horário eles vão
cortar o que eles vão fazer o que eles
vão aprender os amigos que eles vão sair
para que isso dê certo
eles vão criando um ambiente que é mais
um espaço maior do sistema e se eles não
têm esse mesmo crime
quero fazer uma conversa sobre o assunto
a gente vê isso nos possa acontecer com
os melhores e direta
eles não estão chegando eles não
criticando a realidade eles conseguem
transformar e às vezes causam
transformações que nem são tão boas para
eles assim isso eles gente vai fazer o
ambiente característico dessas pessoas é
e outra coisa porque acho que tem um
ponto de eu não acredito que seja uma
carta que faz com que eles façam isso
acredito que é o grande que eles têm de
estar fazendo trabalhando dessa maneira
isso estágio de evolução a pessoa nasceu
assim elas vão aprendendo e vão criando
a possibilidade de a menina compensa
porque a gente que elas têm é que eu
acho que você é e quanto mais e menos e
ofereço a empresa faz o que é mais
lógico e menos o mais lógico
penso pessoas quiserem se no espaço que
o desejo para vocês do fundo do meu
coração é que essas luzes que ascenderam
hoje elas não parem
vocês perguntam que todos os dias elas
se mantenham acesos em que você deixe um
legado muito obrigado